funny hey Tony Tony what's up Uncle Tom
congratulations Anthony cheers let's see
how can i count the way that I remember
one time tony was to my alter ego mama
chef hi Tony thank you for always having
my back thank you for always kind of
being a sounding board and keep doing
you man you best I'm raising a class of
bend over and say in your honor I hope
you have a beautiful birthday
celebration I think the first and most
important thing is that you've always
understood the value of good dishwashers
and combustibles secondarily that you
take people to see and understand food
not just to make the culture of
deliciousness that was part of almost
every single part
funny story i got with my connection
with you was the first time I met you I
was so nervous and I he walked in the
Hamish o'clock in Koreatown just made me
feel like we known each other forever
man I remember one time tony was on Top
Chef and I think he described Fabio's
dish as chlamydia on a plate now i'm
sure that's just a day at the office for
Tony but for us at judge's table that
was quite a zinger I remember 20 years
ago coming home from an exhausting
service and the whole time I wanted to
cook and right that night I got I was
230 in the morning and I flick on the
team and there you were an interview the
first question get asked is how do you
write us to high level and also cook at
such a high level and you said you
describe your day and you said you know
after the dinner service and after all
the vendors you describe that you went
on you would still set your alarm clock
four o'clock in the morning dunk your
head on bowl of ice and write every
single day and I was at the moment that
I thought this is completely possible I
think we should declare 2016 is a year
board aenean revolution so we can have
blood flowing on the plate blood flowing
on the page blood flowing on the screen
of course blood flowing in the streets
keep it up old man or [ __ ] with it
bruh Tony Bourdain has certainly proved
anything is possible
food especially for us where I me lying
books I'm not so sure how my extremely
intoxicated Waffle House Tour stacks up
to his latest experience eating noodles
with the president I love it that we met
when we were having a fight on Twitter
and what that showed to me was that you
just give a damn about everything and
everybody and this industry and you've
made me a more thoughtful person about
the people who make and sell and bring
me my food thank you so much everybody
wants to know what's Anthony Bourdain
like I'll tell you what he's like he's
just a regular guy it's kind of mellow
now he's got a wife and a kid before
that it was a wild while me I mean over
the years you have inspired so many
people all over the world to travel to
discover our new culture to go to the
markets to eat street food I want just
to say thank you so much for everything
you have done for all of us to my artery
Tony you look so much better with my
hair but thank you for teaching us a
showing of new places we love you have a
great first thing alright meet Tony I me
Tony belikova what a show tune of a
super sorry skipper i bought a little
more TP so Nancy do some multi boost or
forty be so sexy piece a clue a clue a
clue not to be Tony a clue a clue
totally a clue a clue a clue a clue a
clue a clue a clue a clue get me la de
todo el abuso be a couple days over
Satan evil you're such a whiner cassato
you're happy birthday and
happy birthday happy birthday I want to
be sure that your birthday is 60th
birthday happy birthday to you
congratulations to me happy birthday
happy 60th birthday happy happy birthday
old man happy 60th birthday of all the
on earth I assume that you are gonna
live